let's go for yip chess
let's hope she doesn't have the yips
today uh karissa yep
i am i think she's still a junior as
well from the uh
from the um united states
of america
um
let's get it going
shadow sock nap yeah
vincent is too classical he's he's not
enough of a hustler
not enough of a hustler to
to pull that off
but
his jazz understanding as you could see
from that game
is is sublime
uh let's go c3 this time a little bit
more classical
it's becoming a theme
theme tournament in
close race
and here one of the points of this line
is that you can get to
c2 in one go so you don't get black give
black time for knight a5
and then c5 if the bishop was here on b3
i played this as uh
as um black and white a bunch myself
it's very interesting because there are
so many
um positional plans for
for both sides
i'm going to turn the light up a little
bit
no i'm getting blinded
[Music]
a4 maybe
before i go f
uh a5
okay this is an old favorite of mine as
well the old
pinning the
the
the knight and then bring the knight to
e3
generally isn't great but
i do get some active pieces so
it's not too bad
queen d7 she's playing very
decently so far
uh probably 98 is reasonable now
bring the knight to to e6 later on
i had some similar game against brazon
back in 2006
and then at some point i just went
berserk and went
g4 g5
i won the game but
truth be told it was pretty
unclear along the way and it wasn't
obvious that i should have
97
i'm a little less sure about because i'm
not sure
where the knight is going from there i
would have preferred to see knight d8
and then
uh knight e6
there
uh i guess this one is reasonable but
still the knight on on
e7 feels a bit funky
i think i'll go queen c2 i'm not worried
about g5 so that's a pretty
big weakening of her position
now after a knight of four
um
i think i will go bishop
bishop
[Music]
to g3
d5 doesn't feel entirely right to me
i don't think she's ready for this
and besides when she takes an e4 i think
the position is going to only going to
open up for my pieces
i think i'll go h3 for the moment
intending knight g4
now once again the knight in e7 is
i think very much in the way
both from defending
e5 and also
now the queen doesn't protect f7 and
this means that
there are many tactical lines that could
potentially work for me
now i think knight g5 should be
necessary knight g4 should be fairly
strong i don't see a comfortable way to
deal with uh
um
to deal with the threat on on e5
if um
yeah if queen d6 i didn't actually
consider that move
but i think d4 must be strong ed4
there's
e5
and if d4
i got bishop f7 and then
knight e5 and also 95 immediately should
win
so i think i i should be winning now
um
yeah 95 this should
probably be the this is probably the
cleanest stamp
bish b5 d5
wins a piece
and otherwise
also a 95 obviously wins
knight ed5 i just go
bishop f4 and then take an f7 and here
this is carnage as well
knight f7 with the nasty
discovery
and now here i'll just take on
uh take on b5 then rook rook a7
evolving all my my guys in to the play
and then later i can take an e4 95 and
um a bunch of material up for the
winning position
yeah uh i think like the only conceptual
mistake she made there in that game was
97 i think it's fairly instructive
actually
that
in itself moving the knight it's
reasonable both preparing potential d5
and
also
um
also a potential c5 but
probably she should have spent two moves
rather than one to put it on a on a
beard square